ya vimos por qué grecia está mal en los
vídeos pasados pero aquí hay más
información mira hay un coeficiente muy
grandote de deuda contra producto
interno bruto por acá también tenemos
una economía débil reflejada en esta
gráfica de desempleo que va de octubre
de 2010 a marzo de 2012 y mira desde
2010 el porcentaje ya era muy alto y
continuó subiendo hasta los veintitantos
en el 2012 es un número bien alto y lo
que es peor es que esto todavía no nos
da la situación muy precisa porque ver
si nos vamos a los jóvenes si nos vamos
a la tasa de desempleo para las personas
de 25 26 o sea de veintitantos años es
mucho más alta que ésta que de por sí es
altísima por otro lado también tenemos
que el mercado de bonos expresa esta
preocupación a través de tasas muy altas
para grecia esto de acá son las tasas de
interés a largo plazo que se le piden
entonces las posibles opciones que tenía
a grecia ya platicamos algunas de esas
déjame le escribo por acá
grecia entonces sus posibles opciones
serán las siguientes la primera que es
la única en la cual se pueden quedar en
la zona europea es que alguien le
suscriba un cheque muy muy grande de
mucho dinero para
pueda pagar una gran cantidad de su
deuda entonces una opción es que haya un
rescate financiero un rescate financiero
por el resto de la unión europea aquí
pues alemania es un actor muy importante
porque tiene una economía bien grande la
más grande de europa pero con el rescate
financiero hay condiciones la gente dice
sabes que debes de cortar sus excesos
debes de empezar a administrar bien las
cosas y de este modo cualquier solución
del rescate financiero está muy
entrelazada con algún tipo de austeridad
bueno ya platicamos un poquito acerca de
la austeridad verdad ya dijimos número 1
pues que es políticamente impopular pero
además dijimos que puede ser algo un
poco de miedo verdad porque pues como ya
tenemos una economía muy débil como el
desempleo tiene un porcentaje muy alto
pues qué sucede si nos ponemos más
austeros de lo que estamos qué pasa si
hacemos un corte drástico del gasto
gubernamental en este momento uff pues
esta tasa podría crecer muchísimo de
hecho este aumento tan grande que tuvo
en estos años se debió a las últimas
rondas de austeridad y por eso la gente
de grecia está sospechando mucho de esta
medida pero bueno si ésta
no es la opción que grecia toma la única
otra opción la única que es viable es
salirse del euro es decir abandonar la
la eurozona la eurozona es el conjunto
de países de europa que decidieron
utilizar al euro como su moneda vale y
pues ya platicamos un poquito de esta
opción y ya dijimos que no sería fácil
verdad tendrían que abandonar la zona
europea ya lo mejor moverse al no ser el
nuevo dracma al dracma nuevo dracma
griego y con esto pues habría una gran
devaluación comparados con el euro de
modo que los ahorros desaparecerían pero
a lo mejor no completamente los ahorros
se devaluaría y claramente el pueblo
griego sabe esto como la gente ya sabe
que esto puede pasar y cada vez se ve
más y más probable entonces la gente
está empezando a retirar muchísimo a
hacer retiros masivos para sacar sus
euros para guardarlos en el colchón y
que no se devalúan en dracmas pero eso
tiene un efecto muy negativo en el
sistema bancario porque lo que puede
hacer potencialmente es hacer que falle
completamente vale
y no poner fallas bancarias ok
bueno toda la estrategia verdad de
abandonar la zona europea de dejar el
euro y moverse al dracma tendría que ver
con aprovechar la inflación para evitar
las obligaciones para disminuir su valor
en valor nominal pero esa inflación que
ya ha pasado antes en el pasado podría
fácilmente convertirse en hiperinflación
hiperinflación entonces tanto si vemos a
la austeridad en la realidad del rescate
financiero o bien acá en la situación de
salirse del euro al parecer a mediano
plazo la economía va a fallar
completamente entonces no es muy claro
como fuera de un rescate financiero muy
generoso
grecia pueda salirse de esta situación
entonces la economía falla completamente
falla completamente completamente ahora
qué sucede si la economía falla casi
completamente así mal plan pues entonces
el desempleo va a ponerse todavía peor
va a crecer muchísimo la tasa para
llevar a intranquilidad social y ya no
estamos hablando de 9 10 por ciento de
desempleo como
en eeuu sino como de 2030 incluso más
alto de lo que ahorita está pasando la
gente empieza a intranquilizarse sobre
todo los jóvenes que pongo aquí
intranquilidad social y luego tenemos
radicalización la gente joven o bueno
cualquier persona cuando ve que no puede
llevar comida a su casa comida a su mesa
entonces empieza a hacerle caso a las
personas que tienen ideas más radicales
eso por sí mismo ya es una cosa por la
cual preocuparse la historia de europa
nos dice que incluso cuando países muy
pequeños empiezan a caer en este tipo de
intranquilidad social puede tener un
efecto muy grande en toda europa justo
como sucedió en la primera y segunda
guerra mundial
así fue como empezaron entonces tan solo
esta razón es suficiente para que la
gente piense muy seriamente acerca de
hacer un rescate financiero y pero bueno
el rescate viene con otras consecuencias
verdad qué pasa si hacemos un rescate
financiero para grecia que no se supone
que esto en cierta forma premia y premia
la mala administración y el mal gasto
mala administración y pues no sólo eso
sino que también premia lo que
platicamos de las cuentas oscuras de las
cuentas turbias entonces esto parece ser
un muy buen contra argumento digamos
para un ciudadano alemán para no andar
le escribiendo cheques de rescate a
grecia porque seguir dándoles dinero sin
que les duela los griegos por su parte
dicen que si es que ya tomamos mucho
daño ya hubo varias rondas de austeridad
que dañaron la economía muchísimo y si
hacen que nos duela todavía más entonces
vamos a caer en una situación crítica en
una situación terrible muy fea con mucha
intranquilidad social entonces ahorita
realmente estamos desesperados y la
verdad ahorita no es un buen momento
para plantearnos una moraleja por eso la
gente está preocupada pero hay una razón
más grande puede ser que grecia no sea
el único país bueno claramente es el
primero y al que le está yendo peor pero
si grecia falla completamente en una
manera económica y social o más
importante si la zona europea no es
capaz de rescatar a grecia entonces es
una señal implícita para el resto del
mundo de que europa no es capaz de
rescatar a sus países cuando están en
problemas entonces
vamos a esta gráfica de por acá a esta
mira grecia no es el único país
claramente es el peor pero abajito de
grecia tenemos a portugal tenemos una
tasa de interés muy alta como por el 12
13 por ciento y mira por acá
portugal tiene el 93 por ciento de deuda
contra pib y también tiene un desempleo
más o menos alto si se le permite a
grecia abandonar la zona europea y no se
le rescata entonces los inversionistas
se van a empezar a preocupar por
portugal van a pensar que la gente no lo
va a querer rescatar le van a empezar a
pedir más interés para para poder
prestarle dinero y que pague sus gastos
que tiene que hacer pero cada incremento
en un punto porcentual de la tasa de
interés pues va a hacer que se consuma
más del producto interno bruto de
portugal vive aquí deuda contra el
producto interno bruto es casi 100 por
ciento si tienen que pagar un 1 por
ciento más entonces va a empezar a
acabarse más el producto interno bruto y
va a forzar a que la economía de
portugal se haga más y más lenta y esto
ya no suena conocido empieza a irse en
la misma dirección que grecia
portugal tampoco es el único italia
también tiene una deuda pib muy alta
irlanda también y mira españa el
desempleo esta aguja por los cielos
entonces el miedo o bueno creo que hay
dos grandes miedos el primero es que
grecia por sí mismo puede volverse un
punto de inestabilidad pero la segunda
preocupación es que si esto no se
remedia esto puede hacer un cierto
contagio o reacción en cadena por toda
europa en la cual la gente se empieza a
lugar y deja de rescatar financieramente
a todos los países lo cual es terrible
porque va a causar que todos estos
abandonen la eurozona